The Joe Rogan Experience hey Rob if
you're listening I want to go to your
house and I do have my passport image
he's in jail oh I'll still go to your
house I mean the guy's an artist my
favorite line in that song is he goes
[ __ ] I wish you would burn my
[ __ ] clothes
because you can tell she just said I'm
gonna burn her clothes yeah
[ __ ] I wish you would burn my
[ __ ] clothes it's just real
conversations
it's so funny to get caught cheating and
like think you have a good points were
there other guys right did she say that
back yeah tell me this gotcha how the
[ __ ] she know I was with them other
girls
it's amazing I might start sing fighting
with my girlfriend she's like yeah
she's like stop playing Xbox i'm like
[ __ ] I like playing Xbox what's amazing
is how many years he got away with doing
what he was doing because all this real
talk was after the videotape got
released the Chappelle sketch was in
2003-ish that's right yeah that's what
it was a known thing that he'd like to
piss on young chicks and this was right
this was 2007. never got edited out of
the movie it was funny
yeah that was a huge thing that was
crazy now he's in jail
[Music]
they try to delay the sentencing just
yesterday and that got denied so it's
May 4th and he faces 10. we should go
wait wait what's he in trouble for
tricking [ __ ]
pretty much no he's not treble there's
underage [ __ ] there's a lot oh yeah
there's many things just like
imprisonment I hope he's saying saying
defenses
I'd like to represent myself can I say
one more thing yeah what are the charges
sex trafficking excuse me convictions
sex trafficking
oh he was getting girls
I mean he would just maybe they must be
miners but I think he was getting girls
from like Ohio or wherever
any woman or girl cross street lines for
any immoral purpose oh no we're all in
trouble oh yeah right what's immoral
right that's because sodomy is like
isn't like that's a little oral sex is
illegal in some states that's true so if
you a girl comes across the state line
to visit you and blow you that's always
trying to tell girls
federal charges of child pornography and
obstruction of just separate oh that's
separate I'm actually with the people
that deny this dude
free free cows
he's innocent dude
find the video of him singing in jail
go to Reddit wait what yeah he's in jail
singing for the for the fellas I thought
that was a joke no I I've seen a video
of him singing in jail and it's [ __ ]
good prisons R Kelly from singing true
yeah
he's telling me yes
[Applause]
there is
he's so good
he's basically saying don't rape me guys
please whatever you want this is the
more my body is telling me yes that's
he's talking about gay sex in jail there
is a video going around I sent this a
girl last night because it's like his
style uh those that's gonna get the boys
fired up fired that song in there oh
yeah give you hope yeah I'd like to have
sex with that guy yeah you finish that
song go now go out there and we're gonna
go rape
go get those white guys on in here on
DUI this video
My Mind Is Telling Me No my body's
telling me that was like one of his big
hits yeah it was wow
see if there's any other videos of him
in jail
who's got a YouTube
or something caught singing to a girl on
Tick Tock from jail wow try that it's an
hour and 15 minute videos
can you sing a song for me
love letter
did you get my call
did you look in my car the voice of an
Angel
[Music]
when your dad goes to the same prison as
R Kelly
[Music]
thank you that's adorable
same prison as R Kelly that is wild